[Musique]
j'ai eu beaucoup d'appréhension quant
aux mamies ici j'ai pu aussi de
l'isolément et bon ben c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé tout de suite elles ont eu
que j'étais que je me retirais tout ça
et puis elles revenaient toutes ya sayah
sayan alors il faut venir jeanine
famille est que c'était tellement chaud
que j'ai dit à l'étuvée doit pas faire
tâter mita grognon faut que tu t'y m et
j'ai causé avec elle des choses comme
une maman à une fille
[Musique]
l'arrivée des jeunes en service civique
ça nous a permis d'être beaucoup plus
près de chaque personne de répondre à
leurs besoins de vis social encore
davantage et notamment aussi de garder
un contact avec des générations de
jeunes générations et en général ils ont
des tas de choses à se raconter et
l'échangé est vraiment intéressant et
les liens secrets
[Musique]
il
il faut savoir que en tant qu'éducateur
spécialisé on a certaines valeurs à
avoir quand même comme de la patience et
met l'humain
et donc du coup dans ce service civique
je retrouve toutes ses valeurs et je me
découvre aussi puisque je peut remarquer
que plus sensible que je ne le pensais
par exemple je découvre plein de choses
sur moi-même et voilà au niveau des
valeurs aussi jacquard beaucoup de
valeur qui cet échange un peu
intergénérationnel donc on parle chacun
de notre génération que c'est c'est
aussi comment dire
remontant entre guillemets enfin c'est
valorisant accompagner les résidants
dans des rendez vous etc
je trouve ça trop basse et un moment
comme moi intime parce que c'est leur
rendez-vous personnel
[Musique]
d'abord c'est est extrêmement poignant
je dois dire et ensuite je retiens que
en fait c'est une expérience de
réciprocité parce que les personnes
âgées reçoivent autant que les jeunes
eux-mêmes près je crois vraiment le
service civique c'est une expérience
pour la vie pour les jeunes et pour
toutes les personnes qui peuvent
dialoguer avec ces jeunes
[Musique]